health experts and diplomats are
preparing for days of tense talks with
the world health assembly which starts
in a few hours time the annual meeting
is the governing body of the world's
health organization
and should be focused on combating the
coronavirus
but disputes between global rivals are
threatening to
overshadow the assembly it's being
hosted at the who in geneva
but will largely take place online the
u.s
is again expected to attack the
organization and its leadership
which it accuses of being too lenient on
china
the u.s has also been pushing for the
who to end its exclusion of taiwan
china which claims taiwan is its
territory has been blocking its
participation
for several years now that means that
one of the countries
that's been most successful at combating
the coronavirus pandemic
won't have a seat at the table taiwan
responded quickly to the outbreak
and has suffered relatively few
infections and deaths
we have this report now from the capital
taipei
no lockdown of any kind despite its
proximity to china
taiwan is one of the few spots on earth
where life has continued close to normal
throughout the pandemic
with only a few hundred coronavirus
infections
and less than 10 deaths taiwan's
handling of the crisis
is a unique success story all the more
surprising
that the who doesn't seem to be
interested in taiwan's approach
the organization blocked taiwan from
taking part in its annual meeting
several years ago
under pressure from beijing that has
deprived the island of access to crucial
information
about the virus we were successful yes
but without that platform it was very
hard
like we don't have many serious cases so
treatment
modalities protocols for serious cases
are lacking in taiwan we need to stop
this kind of political rhetoric we need
to
hold on to the more important issues
like help of everyone involved
dr lou used to be a delegate to the who
when taiwan was still allowed to attend
the assembly as an observer
but that ended on beijing's behest when
taiwan's president from the
pro-independence party took
office four years ago china claims the
island as its own territory
and therefore deems taiwan has no right
to who membership
politics should be set aside when it
comes to health issues
it's good for taiwan to share its
experience with the world
taiwan has made a contribution to public
health
it's unfair to be excluded
taiwan has maintained its infection rate
lower than almost anywhere else
with zero domestic infections for over a
month
even so the taiwanese haven't let their
guard down
perhaps this is one of the things the
world and the w.h.o
could learn from this island
and let's get more we are joined by dr
daniel liu the former taiwanese delegate
to the w.h.o who was also featured in
that report
he joins us from taipei welcome to the
program and thank you so much for being
with us
why is it so important for taiwan to
once again
have a seat at the who's top table
yes glock tournament from taipei and
thank you for this opportunity for me to
speak up a little bit
for our compatriots and and our health
it's so important for us to go to double
jobs not just for this epidemic
alone the pandemic is devastating for a
lot of people
we were scared and we were very uh
and anxious but we managed so far
but double ratio provide not only for
the infectious diseases
it provides all the all the issues
the platform for all the public health
issues it's just
not fair for us to to go into the blind
and do it
the work all by ourselves without
collaboration and and and help from
each other in the international stage
and given the ongoing geopolitical
tensions you know
we mentioned um that you are excluded as
a member so that's that is part of that
how confident are you therefore that the
who will be able to reach a consensus
on the ultimate goal which is tackling
this pandemic
for the public health alone we
are confident that this issue is being
addressed will be addressed
quite
concordantly these
is affecting the life of everybody
but we are so also afraid that
political issues being raised by certain
members of who might make
this uh approach for public health
are quite tedious to tackle
so what is your message then to the who
and those
certain members that you've referenced
um is that
we need to look beyond the politics
the health is actually more important
than anything else
without looking at the health of at more
fundament
as a more fundamental human right
just like other right to leave
right to better living right to a
better livelihood right to better
economy
everything being considered in under
this international of
a big family should be
in front up front not politics
we our colleagues and us have been
trying very hard
not to put political issues ahead of
ahead of this request to be involved
with with fellow public health and the
uh health workers in the world
if every time we need to compromise
politics
and compromise in this agenda to succumb
to their demand
and i don't think it's not fair at all
we
we humbly request a space
for us to chat and work together
for help well we thank you so much for
joining us to share that perspective dr
daniel lou
former taiwanese delegate to the w.h.o
we appreciate it
thank you very much